you voice the villain is that right yeah
in Captain Underpants correct and I my
character can I say it in in character
the main characters full name you may do
whatever you like my character's name is
Professor PP diamine steam poopypants
Esquire okay so you are professor
poopypants oh yes for short yes is this
did you choose this role because it
relates to anything in your life at all
or no you just do I'm offered are you
saying are you cutting claiming that I
pooped my pants cuz that's not true I'm
not a I'm not a little kid that's what
kids do I've never pooped my pants
you say you've never pooped your I'm
going on record as saying Connor and
I've never pooped my pants let's show
this real clip from my interview with
Nick Kroll about five years ago I had
had a couple morning meetings a couple
different cups of coffee different
blends and then the last meeting was
fruit smoothie and then I'm like oh no
no this this caterpillar wants to become
a butterfly and I get in front of my
house and I'm like you know fill my
underwear
we'd like a travel sized pillow worth
the brisket
fake news yeah
fake news you know that's an old clip I
was in my brawny that the towel yeah
Jelena Khalid I yeah which beards I got
I took your beard trips at least it took
yeah
you